it's always good to know who's doing the
digging so in this section I will talk
about Jorge Andrew Reisner short
biographical sketch Reisner was born in
1867 in Indianapolis that makes him a
Hoosier he came to Harvard in the class
of 1889 and in the last few years of his
studies he became interested in Semitic
languages ancient cultures of the
ancient Near East he'd first heard about
this in some of his high school classes
back in Indianapolis he graduated in the
class of 1889 and you see a class
photograph here in this picture along
the way he studied under David Gordon
Lyon Lyon was the one who founded the
Harvard Semitic museum got this building
built in 1903 that you see here and he
was really the father of what is now the
Department of Near Eastern languages and
civilizations Reisner went home to
Indianapolis after getting his BA degree
and worked in a law firm and then he
came back to Harvard for his master's
degree in 1891 and his PhD in 1893 along
the way he took time out to go back home
and marry the girl next door
Mary Bronson David Gordon Lyon had
studied in Leipzig and he felt it was
important for Eisner to have the
experience of a German academic
institution so he sent him off to Berlin
and it's there that Reisner began his
Egyptological career remember at Harvard
it was all about Semitic languages so
Biblical Hebrew Akkadian cuneiform
inscriptions and the like it was at
Berlin that he met the great
Egyptologist Adolph airmen who had
studied so many phases of the Egyptian
language and his star pupil Court Zeta
and in the Berlin Museum Reisner learned
Egyptian all phases of the language from
Zeta he thought everything was set after
spending three years at Berlin and he
came back to Harvard and taught for a
year but to his great surprise there was
no money to keep him and so all seemed
lost until he got a letter from Berlin
from one of his colleagues Ludwig
Borchardt
inviting him to come to Cairo and be
part of an international commission to
study and publish objects in the
chipton museum this was his first
good-paying job and of course he jumped
at it so here is a photograph of the
International Commission team members
from several different countries all
working on different aspects of the
Egyptian Museum collection it was here
in Cairo that Reisner met Phoebe
Apperson Hearst mother of the newspaper
magnate William Randolph Hearst she was
looking for excavators to support
projects all over the world in Egypt too
for the University of California
Berkeley
so in 1899 Hearst and Reisner signed an
agreement and he decided to change
directions completely from Semitic
philology to Egyptian object publishing
and become an archaeologist this was a
whole right turn for him and the
agreement called for him basically to
learn on the job
not a bad understanding if you can get
it and so he started in Upper Egypt
southern parts of the country working at
quote-unquote less important sites in
order to hone his craft inventing survey
techniques and record-keeping for his
excavations this map shows you some of
the early sites that he worked at and
there's a photograph of the camp at Naga
Adair which came to be a very important
site ultimately but it was later on in
1903 that the Giza necropolis became
available there had been just too much
illicit digging and Reisner was not the
only one complaining to the Egyptian
Antiquities authorities then of course
under French control under Gaston
Maspero Maspero allowed several
different expeditions to come together
and Amelie divided up the site and this
is what happened so in this section I'm
just going to talk about reissner's
excavations in another module you've
seen how the site was divided between
the German later German Austrian the
Italian and the American concessions
this plan shows the dates in red type
for how Reisner moved all across the
necropolis he began in 1904 at the far
western edge of the site and moved
gradually eastwards towards the Great
Pyramid along the way he picked up a
student from Harvard Albert Morton
Lithgow who had transferred from Brown
to come to Harvard and had been trained
at the American School in Athens and
elsewhere Lithgow would later leave to
become the first curator at the
Metropolitan Museum of Art
everything was going just fine until
Phoebe Hearst ran into financial trouble
and she needed to pull out from
supporting the excavation this was in
1904 1905 and this was a catastrophe
so in the summer of 1905 Lithgow came
back to Harvard first and Reisner
followed later and the idea was to try
to get the Museum of Fine Arts Boston
and/or Harvard University interested in
picking up the excavation so this began
what I call the intriguing summer of
1905 and this photograph shows you many
of the players we have Harvard's
president Eliot looking after Harvard's
interest David Gordon Lyon reissner's
old professor trying to do right by
everyone Albert mortlake Oh reissner's
supporter and assistant but really had
his own agenda along the way as well and
then on the museum side gardner martin
lane was representing the interests of
the museum so there was a lot of back
and forth and eventually was created the
Harvard University Boston Museum of Fine
Arts expedition here's a photograph of
the old Copley Square building for the
Museum of Fine Arts in those days in
1909 the building moved to Huntington
Avenue the site that it still occupies
today this was a one-year contract and
was meant to expire in 1906 but it
continued as a sort of gentlemen's
agreement between these institutions for
the next 40 years all the way until
reissner's death in 1942 and so the
object started flowing in here was a
photograph of the MFA galleries and you
see some of the Giza masterpieces set up
in the room crates were arriving records
photographed notes publications Reisner
was writing articles in the MFA bulletin
and elsewhere and all of this took place
from the headquarters at what was known
as Harvard camp here you see it on this
aerial photograph the red arrow points
to the location to the west of khafre's
pyramid this was just a simple
collection of mud brick huts but it
eventually grew over the years it had
the engineers offices the photo studios
reissner's office a dining area and of
course sleeping quarters this photograph
shows you the courtyard which was always
choked with objects fragments of pottery
stone vessels and from here a lot of the
colossal statues came together there's
also a computer Maude
we've made of this area and it's
important to remember that Reisner was
not only famous for developing
archaeological method and these great
documentation systems at the Giza
pyramids but all up and down the Nile
here is a photograph of him working all
the way down south in Nubia he was
basically the father of Nubian
archeology as well
this image shows one of the class
notebooks the class of 1889 and you can
see how Reisner is aging eventually by
the 1930s he was the grey eminence he
was the sage up at Harvard camp and
everyone would come to consult him not
only about matters archaeological but
political issues as well remember you
have the British running the government
you have the French controlling the
antiquities service and the Egyptians of
course desiring their own independence
along the way so this photograph from an
Arabic newspaper shows him an advanced
age unfortunately he's losing his sight
by this time but again he was the master
the expert whom so many came to consult
and I couldn't help noticing recently on
the internet this photograph of some
mirrored sunglasses that show the
pyramids reflecting and I got a chuckle
because Reisner had done this already
before we can compare this Internet
image to the photograph taken from that
Arabic newspaper and you can see the
pyramid reflecting in reissner's glasses
as well there was even a live broadcast
the first time ever made by NBC right
from the pyramids on a cold winter
evening in February 1938 Reisner and the
team assembled on the North Face of the
Khufu pyramid and they broadcast live
this would have been dinner time back
home in the US but it was about 11:00
p.m. in Cairo and he narrated some of
the excavation work loads and some of
his assistant spoke as well and a famous
radio personality inside the Kings
chamber inside Khufu also broadcast this
required miles of cable going down to
the Mina House Hotel off the edge of the
plateau and then briefly just some of
his trusted assistants there was dows
Dunham a Harvard student who had come
out to Giza and became Rhys doors
right-hand man also working in Nubia and
then eventually coming back to the
Museum of Fine Arts being in all but
name the chief curator as all the crates
and the objects and the monuments came
in there was another Harvard student
named Willie
Stevenson Smith he too eventually became
a successor and curator in the Egyptian
Department after reissner's death great
art historian who published many
important works about the Old Kingdom
and the pyramid age and then Reisner
befriended a couple Joseph Linden Smith
and his wife Karina Smith was a painter
who'd studied at the school of the
Museum of Fine Arts and elsewhere
turning from portrait painting he found
his true love coming out to Egypt every
year and painting scenes in Giza tombs
temples Nubia Egypt everywhere so he
became great friends with Reisner and
they enjoyed their company very much
reisender was not such a great fan of
the burgeoning color photography process
but he thought the oil paintings made by
Smith were tremendously valuable and
there are well over a hundred of them
today and then finally we have syed
ahmed Siyad one of his fifties these are
the egyptian foremen from a town in
upper egypt who ran the show and messiah
Ahmed was whenever eisenerz most trusted
individuals took him on as a
photographic helper and a boy and he
spent decades with the expedition
unfortunately he died in 1926 during the
excavation of the head of Harris tomb
but side sons Muhammad and Mahmoud went
on to follow in this tradition and they
ran everything at the expedition after
that keeping the accounts keeping the
men in line doing the pay stubs for
everyone one of them learned English and
was typing up a lot of the manuscripts
as well Reisner was only able to come
back to America four or five times to
teach at Harvard remember World War one
got in the way and delayed things and
his very last trip was in 1939 when he
got an honorary degree of the Harvard
commencement this was his 50th
commencement anniversary after that he
returned to his beloved Harvard camp
remember he's pretty much blind by this
time World War two breaks out he sends
his wife and daughter home to America
they had quite a circuitous route but
they finally made it and in 1942
unfortunately after a long stroke and
basically being bedridden Reisner died
at Harvard camp behind the pyramids
he's buried in the old part of Cairo in
the American Cemetery and his men and
the Museum of Fine Arts team composed
this text that you see on the screen
here and this is the inscription that
you read when you visit his tombstone
today back at Giza
you can still see vestiges of the great
era of excavations some of these rusting
debris carts and even railroad tracks
some of them still used today that were
used to move the large mounds off of the
mastaba tombs during all those decades
of excavation
you